love him or hate him there is no denying
that Adam Sandler knows how to entertain
his fans and Netflix couldn't be happier
with the results
since the company started producing its
own content in 2011 Netflix has sought
out Partnerships with a variety of
established producers writers directors
and actors many of these professionals
are well known and respected within
their industry but that cloud doesn't
always translate to audience interest or
attention the likes of Denzel Washington
bong Joon ho Charlie Kaufman and Steven
Soderbergh have made movies for Netflix
celebrities such as Will Smith and
Charlize Theron have headlined major
projects for the streamer as well but
even more so than film auteurers and
action Stars Adam Sandler is a brand
unto himself
Sandler has accumulated his fan base
over the course of more than 30 years
the comedian first became a household
name on Saturday Night Live where he was
a cast member from 1990 to 1995. in
short order SNL launched Sandler into a
lucrative film career that began with
1995's Billy Madison and continues to
this day with his Netflix deal
want a piece of me
on a PCU I want the whole thing
he's prolific with more than 80 credits
to his name and a few of his films are
genuine Classics one could argue that no
SNL Alum has had Sandler's staying power
stars like Eddie Murphy Mike Myers and
Will Ferrell may have had higher Highs
but they've all fallen off for long
periods and they've struggled to
maintain their leading man status in
more recent years Sandler's remarkably
hard-working and consistent which is
probably why Netflix was so eager to
bring him into that fold and is so happy
to keep him on board
Sandler is no doubt best known for
portraying the doofus Everyman in truth
there is not much difference between
Bobby Boucher and huby DuBois and his
fans are fine with that low brow
comedies that are basically SNL style
sketches drawn out to 90-ish minutes
account for the bulk of his resume and
when he's not affecting a goofy accent
or involved in some form of hijinks he
often stars in more traditional romantic
comedies or family movies like 50 First
Dates click and pixels but while Sandler
continues to make his traditional comedy
Fair he's also busy turning in
praiseworthy performances and awards
caliber films many of these still
qualify as comedies though some are
significantly more High Brown not to
mention dark Sandler's first foray into
serious acting came in Paul Thomas
Anderson's 2002 dramedy punch drunk love
that performance earned him a Golden
Globe nomination he received even more
accolades for his role as Howard Ratner
in 2019's uncut jams though he was
snubbed for a widely expected ostronaut
Beyond those critically praised roles
and over-the-top comedies he's
occasionally toned things down in his
movies this includes films for Netflix
like 2000 and 17's the meyerowitz
stories new and selected most recently
he co-produced and led the well-like
sports dramedy hustle for the streamer
and again was a fixture on the awards
circuit in fact in 2023 he was presented
with the Mark Twain Prize for American
humor Netflix surely wants Sandler for
his signature Happy Madison lamp riots
but it doesn't hurt that he can also
deliver Powerhouse performances and more
grounded roles
hey do you love this game
I love this game I live this game
what does well in movie theaters has
certainly changed since the early days
of Adam Sandler's film career in the
1990s Studio comedies regularly topped
box office charts Wayne's World Pretty
Woman Ace Ventura Pet Detective
Sandler's own The Waterboy and There's
Something About Mary we're all among the
top 20 grossing films in the years of
their releases these days it's unusual
for a comedy of any sort to crack that
ceiling none Managed IT in 2022 the
Julia Roberts and George Clooney LED
throwback ticket to Paradise was
considered a Triumph when it managed to
break into the top 30. by and large
comedies live on streaming platforms now
and Netflix is an industry leader in
premiering light-hearted non-ip fare
directly onto audiences TVs there are
several reasons for this and why Sandler
movies in particular do so well as a
result of the shift in viewing habits
theatrical showtimes have been eaten up
by sprawling franchises like the MCU and
the Avatar Series in part because
customers can justify paying for what
feels like an event there's no rush to
see a comedy they can't really be
spoiled the visual effects aren't
usually Central to the plot and while is
part of a group can enhance the
experience that can still be
accomplished with friends and family in
a living room for the price of a monthly
subscription Sandler's comedies are
plentiful and broadly appealing for
those merely looking for something fun
to watch on Netflix
Studio comedies disappeared from Cinemas
in part because all mid-budget movies
seem to vanish from the theatrical
landscape this occurred because big
budget franchise installments and low
budget horror flicks started to squeeze
them out just last year top gun Maverick
made nearly 1.5 billion dollars on 170
million dollar budget while the Indie
creep Fest Cinema rink made about 2
million dollars but cost only fifteen
thousand dollars as of late a 40 or 50
million dollar comedy anchored by a one
spankable a-lister seems like a gamble
if not a losing bet so a slightly
smaller scale Studio films have on the
whole migrated to streaming Netflix
assigned several nine-digit
multi-picture agreements they've worked
over about 450 million dollars for just
two of Ryan Johnson's Knives Out sequels
so Sandler's original deal which
guaranteed him 250 million dollars for
four films is a bargain by comparison no
details have been released about a new
commitment between Sandler and Netflix
the comedies like his with a price tag
of roughly 60 million dollars have so
far clocked in over 2 billion hours of
viewing time it must be a good return
turn on CEO Ted sarandos's investment
even projects that utterly missed the
mark like 2015 spooked the ridiculous
six are still a low-risk high reward
proposition for both Netflix and for
Sandler's happy Madison production
company
well I have a microphone and you don't
so you will
understand
what moviegoers may have noticed that
the length of movies has been itching
ever upward especially in the last few
years not that long ago a three hour
plus run time was extremely unusual
reserved only for the occasional High
fantasy or historical epic the last year
RR Babylon and Avatar the way of water
all surpassed the 180 minute Mark many
more including Steven Spielberg's
autobiographical family drama the Fable
men's and biopics blonde and Elvis
hovered around two and a half hours in
length and Netflix's own the Irishman is
a whopping 209 minutes long that can be
daunting there's no question that
patrons want to get their money's worth
out of a ticket but there's a limit to
audiences free time and attention span
home viewing makes snacks and bathroom
breaks a little easier but still when
subscribers are browsing for something
to watch there's less of a barrier when
the runtime is cut in half Sandler's
trademark comedies tend to fall
somewhere between the 90 and 120 minute
mark on the shorter end the murder
mystery movies are a mere 97 minutes and
90 minutes UB Halloween goes a breezy
103 and the rest ridiculous 6 the
do-over the week of the Meyer witch
stories and hustle all come in under two
hours that means even if home viewers
aren't thrilled with their choice it
won't be a slog to get through and if
you wasted most of your night
indecisively scrolling through Netflix's
infinite content lineup there's probably
still time to fit in an Adam Sandler
movie
just as consumers habits have evolved at
the movie theater they've also evolved
at home too in the last year streaming
has surpassed cable as the way most
customers watch content one consequence
of the significant paradigm shift is
that people no longer flip through
channels to find something to watch nor
do they leave whatever happens to be on
the TV as background noise these days
many viewers seek out specific titles
particularly on the day of a new
streaming release however subscribers
don't always want to be so intentional
subscribers still use their TVs the way
they always have as a means to chill out
Netflix has plenty of artistically
ambitious and thought-provoking original
films to choose from Beasts of the
Southern Wild Roma and All Quiet on the
Western Front are just a few the viewers
aren't always in the mood for something
that requires them to put down their
phones and stay engaged and definitely
not something that's academically or
emotionally challenging sometimes
audiences want a movie they can tune in
and out of though the streamer has been
desperate to win a best pitcher Oscar
and improve its critical reputation
Netflix's customers love the platform
because of its accessible bingeable low
effort properties most Sandler comedies
fit that bill even the more tightly
plotted murder mystery 2 doesn't require
the brain power of Glass Onion when it
comes to how subscribers commonly use
the service Sandler and Netflix's
laid-back hangout Vibes are a perfect
match for each other
the entertainment industry isn't as star
driven as it once was but audiences
still like to see their favorites on
screen it's even better when they're
paired up together if his friends and
co-workers are to be believed Sandler is
one of the most humble and down-to-earth
celebrities working today because he's
easy to work with other big name actors
and directors are happy to get involved
in whatever he's got going on Sandler
regulars like David Spade and Kevin
James tend to pop up in most of his
projects which is a clear indicator of
how much he inspires loyalty but he also
brings along Old PALS like Jennifer
Aniston and Chris Rock celebrated
directors and producers have conceived
films with a comedian in mind too which
is a luxury not many actors enjoy Paul
Thomas Anderson considered himself an
obsessive Sandler fan and so he
challenged himself to make an art house
version of a Sandler comedy with Punch
Drunk Love though it's not currently on
Netflix in the United States the
connection between the director and
actor that developed because of that
film gave Sandler some impressive Indie
cred later Sandler teamed up with writer
director Noah bomback for Netflix's the
meyerowitz stories which co-stars Ben
Stiller as his brother then in 2020 2
Sandler got some of the best reviews of
his career for Netflix's hustle he
co-produced the basketball dramedy with
LeBron James in the end millions of Adam
Sandler fans seek out his movies on
Netflix but because he has such a
variety of famous co-stars and
collaborators their fans end up seeking
out his movies as well despite his
intermittent critical Acclaim in the
fleeting Brilliance of ideas like the
Hanukkah Song Adam Sandler probably
doesn't come to mind when Bill Buffs
think about the world's best actors and
that's part of his appeal he's the type
of performer who understands his
strengths and understands exactly how to
push himself when he chooses to where
Sandler has truly excelled in his
30-plus year career is as a producer not
only has he figured out a filmmaking
formula that's practically market and
critic proof but he's actually ahead of
the curve when it comes to Trends he's
proven himself extremely Savvy about the
types of movies he makes and when he
releases them a perfect example is when
the first murder mystery dropped on
Netflix roughly six months before knives
out he released the entertaining who
done it at exactly the right time before
the much bigger movie premiered in
theaters he also headlined the emotional
no a bombback family drama the meyerwood
stories two years before Adam Driver did
the same in marriage story
and he released his well-regarded sports
movie Hustle before 2023's air Champions
and Challengers it diversifies his
portfolio more than it might seem
Sandler has lent his voice to animated
movies like The Hotel Transylvania
franchise and he had the business Acumen
to make one of his many broad appeal
comedies UB Halloween a holiday offering
it practically assures repeat yearly
viewing as a result the unassuming actor
writer and producer continues to conquer
streaming because he grasps how best to
reach and grow his audience using
Netflix
oh
[Music]